November 8, 2016 was a good night for Donald
Trump.
"I love this country.
Thank you.
Thank you very much."
But it was also a great night for marijuana.
California, Nevada, Massachusetts, and Maine
all approved legalization of recreational cannabis.
And Florida, North Dakota, and Arkansas legalized
medical marijuana.
All told, more than half the states in America
have legalized the drug in one form or another.
So how will the Trump administration deal
with pot?
Which, after all, is still illegal under federal
law.
On the campaign trail, Trump seemed friendly
to the notions of medical marijuana
and leaving the rest to the states.
"I think medical should happen.
Don't we agree?
I mean, I think so.
And then I really believe you should leave it up to
the states.
It should be a state situation."
But signals from his administration have been
more mixed.
"There's still a federal law that we need
to abide by and kind of, in terms of the medical--
when it comes to recreational marijuana."
"I, as you know, am dubious about marijuana."
We asked cannabis industry professionals what
they see
for the future of legal weed in the Trump era.
"I see the future of the marijuana industry
under the Trump administration
as, in the short term, a little cloudy.
But when I say cloudy, it doesn't mean the skies are dark,
it just means it's unclear.
I can never figure out if it's 'Art of The Deal' or not
you know, how much of it's rhetoric and how much of it is going to actually come to pass.
I want a little more clarity before I'm really able to give my opinion.
Trump's attorney general, Jeff Sessions, is a long time drug warrior.
But even he seems reluctant to commit to a full on crackdown.
States I guess can pass whatever laws they choose,
but I'm not sure we're going to be a better, healtheir nation,
that, if we're gonna have marijuana being sold at every corner grocery store.
Attorney general Sessions doesn't have to worry 'cause that's not how the industry works.
It takes a long time to get either a municipal or county permit
and they're highly regulated stores that track seed to store.
There's code, you don't open up near a school.
The people going in to these dispensaries to purchase such product have to be of age.
I think the sitting attorney general is an older gentleman who grew up in a certain context,
and we're all victims of our own context and history.
So I understand his position, why he has those deep-seated feelings.
You know, marijuana is a cure for opiate abuse, give me a break,
I mean, you know this is the kind of argument that has been made out there
just, almost a desperate attempt to defend the harmlessness of marijuana or even it's benefits
I doubt that's true.
Much of modern science contradict's Session's dim view of marijuana's therepeutic potential.
With The National Academies of Sciences, Engineering and Medicine
finding conclusive evidence that cannabis is an effective treatment for chronic pain,
after surveying ten thousand scientific studies on the matter.
Nonetheless, the federal government continues to keep marijuana
in it's most highly controlled category, schedule one.
And recognizes 'no currently accepted medical use'
citing 'high potential for abuse.'
With Sessions helming the department of justice
this classification seems unlikely to change any time soon.
Meaning the tension between state and federal law will remain.
When you look at it being on schedule one, it's a bit absurd
because the definition of schedule one is 'highly addictive and no medical uses.'
And cannabis couldn't be further from the truth on both those criteria
so at the end of the day the truth is marching forward.
While crackdowns on medical cannabis seem unlikely
given Trump's public statements and overwhelming public support for medicinal use.
What about recreational use?
After all, that's a distinction Trump's press secretary Sean Spicer
was careful to make in his comments.
The states where it's allowed in accordance with the appropriations rider
have set forth a process to administer and-
and regulate that usage versus recreational marijuana, that's a very very different subject.
With the largest state in the union legalizing recreational weed
the feds would need to devote major resources to crack down.
And that seems like a fight that most Americans aren't up for either.
With 71% of Quinnipiac poll respondents
opposed to the federal government enforcing laws against marijuana
in states that legalized medical or recreational use.
This dissaproval of federal encroachment on state laws
is pretty consistent across partisan lines.
I've always been a believer in federalism and state's rights
I think it's up to societies and communities to dictate for themselves
what rules they choose to govern themselves by.
Hopefully moving forward the administration will have an open mind about it
and be ready to listen to see how beneficial this has been in the areas where it's been tried.
If if I were in an elevator and had an opportunity to speak to Donald Trump directly
I'd probably invite him for a drink or ask him to sit down over a meal, break some bread
and give me the opportunity to educate him about the true data of the cannabis industry.
It's a job creator, I'm not saying I'm in favor of building a wall,
but if you wanna build a wall, there's potentially a couple billion dollars woth in excise tax revenue.
I don't see anyone pumping the brakes on this big industry.
I see it expanding and doing better.
And helping more people.